so I want to get to something that's
much more important than the debate
which didn't change anything I want to
get to something that might change not
only the 2024 election but our entire
political order something that is so
egregious that it represents I think
without hyperbole an actual crossing of
the Rubicon in the American political
order and it happens to involve a friend
of mine a personal friend of mine along
with a lot of other people who don't
deserve to be uh persecuted in the way
that they're being persecuted the
Liberals are rounding up conservative
dissidents and not just excitable
Midwestern grannies who walked around
the capitol rotunda on January 6th the
worst day in the history of this or any
Republic no
they're they're not even just arresting
the leader of the opposition so insane a
former president so insane
they're arresting
his lawyers
just for
representing him for having the temerity
to provide legal representation to the
then sitting president of the United
States
that is for for making oneself a
dissident against the liberal
establishment regime
these people are now being arrested
including my friend Jenna Ellis who is
coming to us
Jenna first of all thanks for making the
time no you're busy we've been uh
praying for you obviously and following
this closely is I think this is the
first time you you're speaking since
you got out of jail
it is and thank you so much uh Michael
for your friendship and your prayers and
support this has been just an incredibly
insane experience to see that the left
is not only weaponizing government but
they're trying to criminalize the
practice of law
tell me everything that happened I what
before this is so serious that it's
either like you kind of laugh or cry I
mean it's so not even just because it
involves you but
I I just I never imagined this would
happen in the United States we talk
about political prisoners and evil
regimes Russia and communist China and
North Korea
you're a political prisoner you're out
on bond we'll talk about that too but
you're you're a political prisoner as
simple as that I'm wondering which
nation is going to have more political
prisoners by the end of 2024. communist
China communist North Korea Putin's
Russia or good old USFA uh the the only
thing the only thing I'll say to make a
little light of it is arpal Mr Andrew
Clavin did say you have the most
beautiful mug shot ever in the history
of prosecutions but they they took your
mug shot
it's it's so crazy and this is not an
America that I recognize and um you do
have to keep a sense of humor through
this but also realize the gravity of
this and and the reason that I smiled
yesterday was because the left wants to
see us miserable and crying like they
are because they have a false world view
they hate this country they want to tear
down our institutions of government they
want to tear down the constitutionally
protected right to obtain counsel they
want to tear down the practice of
lawyering and so I went in there simply
determined to say not today and I will
face this with resolve and I will face
this with the joy that I have in the
Lord in my faith and with the great a
Christian history and tradition of being
political prisoners of regimes and I am
um overwhelmed actually I never thought
in my lifetime I would stand shoulder to
shoulder with some of those who have
gone before me but um I actually have
this wonderful proof of incarceration
that I was given that I'm going to frame
to show that you know this is something
that is very serious and so I had to
surrender yesterday in Fulton County and
I was taken back and you know you see in
in the jail and you see in the movies
kind of when they do that walk um of
Shame basically with all of the other
prisoners that are behind uh bars and in
the cells together like clamoring and uh
cat calling that literally happened and
so the woman who took me back um and I
won't mention her name but she was
incredibly kind I thanked her afterwards
because she stuck by me the entire time
that I was in that jail with um I was
taken into a place that was just the
general population where there were
other
um mostly men that were around that were
catcalling me that were saying vile
things and she said just look straight
ahead don't worry I will be right here
by your side the whole time and she did
her job and I respect her for that but
this is what this this has come to in
the United States of America that if you
were willing to as a lawyer give legal
advice and provide assistance of counsel
to the leader of the political
opposition then you too will become a
political prisoner and you will be
targeted and and so I spent uh the
afternoon in the Fulton County jail and
now have to report to pre-trial Services
Beyond Bond and they can control any
aspect of my life if I still want to
enjoy my freedom here in the United
States of America and if this is not the
biggest political issue that every
single GOP candidate should have stood
up strongly the debate last night and
said then they don't get what is
happening this is Way Beyond Donald
Trump yeah this is at the very heart of
American Liberties and freedoms and our
institutions I totally agree I can't
tell you I want to bang my head against
a wall when I've heard GOP commentators
and all the genius Consulting class they
say hey we've got to move on stop
talking about 2020 and January 6th and I
just let's just move on stop talking
about it they're rounding up the guy's
lawyers they're rounding up GOP
activists who had the audacity to
question the most secure election ever
in the whole history of Elections going
back to Pericles give me a break if you
raise any question about that as the
liberals do every single time they lose
even if they lose by a country mile now
you could be arrested and
and lose your freedom as you say okay
you're out now you're out on presumably
a pretty pretty high Bond and it's a
thousand dollars a hundred thousand
dollars yeah so where
what is the point of this so what what
is the point for the prosecution to put
you into a jail with a bunch of men
threatening you and Cat calling you what
is the point to take your hundred
thousand dollars what is the point I
guess it's just to humiliate you and
intimidate you and people like you
it's to set us up in as an example to
say that if you want to stand against
the preferred Narrative of the
government then look at what happened to
anyone who is willing to stand with
President Trump and simply represent him
have legal theories and actually act as
lawyers and notice Michael that they're
not doing this to the lawyers who tried
to use a novel argument through the 14th
amendment that Marjorie Taylor green a
sitting congresswoman in Georgia uh
participated in a so-called Insurrection
there were lawyers that were that filed
a case and she actually had to go and
testify they ultimately did not Prevail
but no one is arresting them no one is
coming after their bar licenses for you
know trying to somehow interfere with an
election or you know overturn the
government in terms of her seat I mean
none of this ever applies to anyone else
and any of the leftist lawyers can have
any novel argument that they want to
write in the Atlantic they can say
anything that they want as long as it
goes with the regime's narrative but if
we stand up and actually say no we're
going to fight for Freedom we are going
to make sure to say that every legal
vote counts and counts fairly well then
somehow now that makes you a political
prisoner that makes you
um opposed to America fundamentally and
that makes you worthy of getting
indicted arrested and having to post a
100 000 bond in this country right now
go to goodranchers.com use code Knowles
I don't know about you but this summer
heat in Nashville feels hotter than a
two dollar pistol you know
thanks to the Heat and the inflation
we're feeling the heat in more ways than
one the one thing that I'm not sweating
this hot summer is my meat price
thanks to good ranchers my price is
locked in for two years now you might be
thinking a price lock guarantee on meat
that's crazy as the price of meat
skyrockets well you're right it is crazy
I don't know why they're doing it it's
insane and I don't know how they're
going to make their money back
especially because good ranchers has the
absolute highest quality in the business
it's so freaking good there was I think
it was last week for dinner I had the
good ranchers Burgers which are the
juiciest most delicious burgers you've
ever had in your life and then for
breakfast I had steak and eggs sweet
little Elisa made it was a healthier you
know it was a sirloin it's not like I
was having a big fat ribeye but it's
just all of it the quality is so good I
can't get enough of it right now go to
goodranchers.com use code knowlescana w
l e s for 30 bucks off any box that is
promo code Knowles kwles
goodranchers.com goodranchors.com
American Meat delivered right now text
Knowles to 98 98.98 as central banks in
countries like China India and Australia
begin transitioning to a digital
currency the Federal Reserve has been
contemplating the same for the U.S with
the digital currency the government
could track every single purchase you
make
officials could even prohibit you from
purchasing certain products or easily
freeze or seize part or all of your
money these are some of the reasons that
concerned Americans reach out to Birch
gold
they want to have a physical asset like
gold that is independent of the US
dollar you can protect your IRA or 401K
by diversifying with gold from Birch
gold historically gold has been a safe
haven in times of high uncertainty which
is right now learn if gold is right for
you too text Knowles Canada wlas to 98
98 98 they will send you a free info kit
on gold with an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews I trust Birch gold to help you
diversify into gold if a central bank
digital currency becomes a reality it
will be nice to have some gold to depend
on text Knolls Canada wlie Esther 9898
98 where are you getting the money to do
a hundred thousand dollars a lot of
money
it is and thankfully there's a program
where I only had to put up 10 but still
I mean ten thousand dollars plus cost is
a lot uh and so thankfully you know that
was what I had to post but I am not an
independently wealthy person at all and
um interestingly the uh the Trump pack
the RNC none of these people who are
supposedly are friends and on the same
side are helping to my knowledge any of
us with any of these legal fees so I am
having to fundraise uh for myself and
they're thankfully God's people it's not
even just the political party God's
people and the Christians who understand
what persecution looks like they are
rallying to my defense and I have a
gifts and go it's giftsendgo.com forward
slash support Jenna and I've raised as
of now almost a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars I'm looking at having
to raise probably close to half a
million just to defend this which is
insane and ridiculous but I'm so
grateful for the Christians and the
conservatives who see that this is so
much bigger than who we support in a
presidential primary this is about the
very fabric of Freedom well that that of
course is the irony because obviously
you you were a lawyer for Donald Trump
to my knowledge you're not supporting
him in this Republican primary right so
it's not even like they're just going
after all the hardcore Trump acolytes or
anything like that they're going they're
going after people who support other
candidates they're going after
Republicans they're going after people
who to quote Alan dershowitz a liberal
who also worked as a lawyer for Donald
Trump who just support the Constitution
and they're going to go get you anyway
but that's the point isn't it Jenna
isn't the point even if these charges
are completely bogus as obviously they
are well you're still going to be out
half a million dollars that might teach
you your lesson huh that might
intimidate some other people who might
have the gall to question the liberal
regime
absolutely and that's why this is so
much bigger than Donald Trump or the
idea that this is just targeting him
this is not going to stop whenever
Donald Trump is done with politics this
is about and I stand with all of the
conservatives all of the pastors who
have been targeted with FBI raids with
all of the parents who are being put on
domestic terrorism watch list simply
because they have the audacity to
question what's in their child's state
funded School curriculum with all of the
Christians who uh like my dear friend
and former client Pastor John MacArthur
was threatened with jail time simply for
opening up his church and opposing The
covid Narrative I mean this is beyond a
political party this is all about
destroying fundamental freedoms and
Liberties in this country so we have to
as conservatives understand that bigger
picture that it is not about one
political candidate it's not about one
political party it is all about
opposition to the regime and if we do
not stand up now and understand what
they're doing then we are losing our
freedoms and when I was targeted for my
bar license by uh this democrat-funded
project they specifically went on media
and said the entire goal of this was to
destroy lawyers livelihoods reputations
and credibility they don't care that is
what they want to intentionally destroy
so what are the charges what what as far
as I can tell the crime you committed is
you just were a lawyer last I checked
every client in America not even just
the mean old orange man but even like
murderers and rapists and serial killers
everyone is entitled to Illegal defense
except for conservatives so what what is
the charge they're trying to get you on
right so they they indicted uh 19 of us
including former president Trump with uh
the RICO statute which is the organized
crime Enterprise uh racketeering statute
so uh we are all gangsters now
apparently
um allegedly according to the state of
Georgia and um then specifically I only
have one other count and there's some um
including president Trump have you know
I think he has something like 14 or 17
accounts and all of this
um relates to at least for the lawyers
simply being lawyers and you don't see
any of this against the lawyers for
example from the bush Vigor case um I
think it was Alan dershowitz who said if
this same standard had been employed
back in the year 2000 when ultimately uh
Al Gore did not Prevail and they tried
to come after his lawyers in the same
fashion he said then I would have been
hit with a RICO violation and so this is
again it's just showing the double
standard
so they're saying that you're a mob boss
basically this is re has has the RICO
statute which I didn't know it could be
applied to anything other than organized
crime has this ever has this ever been
applied in in the way that we're seeing
it applied now to a politician's lawyers
not to my knowledge and uh and you're
right that the original intent of the
RICO statute was to prosecute organized
crime like drug rings and sex
trafficking and you know some of these
other um you know obviously really uh
violent crime that is a legitimate
function of government and so while I
can't really get into the specifics of
my own legal defense and I'm very
confident in my counsel uh what I can
say is that this is fundamentally
um taking and manipulating the law and
trying purposefully to apply it to a
scenario that lawyering clearly does not
fall into I mean if every Law Firm were
organized crime Enterprise simply
because they're representing their
client on legal challenges then we would
not have a practice of law or a right to
counsel but that's exactly what they're
targeting you know Jenna I'm glad that
you're confident in your in your Council
and I hope it's a great counsel but the
Democrats the Liberals always accuse us
of the things that they're doing and
never has this been clearer than in this
Rico nonsense the reason that I'm I'm
just a little worried for you I'm I'm
not worried in the sense that we trust
the Lord you know you do your best God
will do the rest what else can we do
Christians have danced and smiled while
they were fed to the Lions but in the
case of this this Rico prosecution
they are behaving like the mob they're
behaving like the five families in New
York and and the Mafia the way that
they're pushing people around and
intimidating people and acting in a
totally Lawless way and so I just fear
if they're willing to even bring these
Preposterous charges
how does one have any hope that justice
will prevail
well that's where I hope that we still
have America as we once knew it and the
America that was founded on the
principles of freedom and liberty and
opposition to tyranny and so if there is
any truth and Justice left in America
then I do believe that I will prevail
because I am innocent of these churches
but you're right uh Michael we've seen
throughout particularly church history
and Christian history that Justice in
this life isn't always accomplished but
that's why my faith in my Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ is what is why I
still have joy because it is possible
that anything could happen we're not
guaranteed to Prevail even in a court of
law even when we are Innocent but that's
not what the Lord calls us to he calls
us to trust him have faith in him and
fulfill the Great Commission which is to
teach the truth of the gospel of Christ
throughout all the world and to stand
Resolute trusting in his sovereignty and
so that's what I am determined to do
through through this whole experience
that I could have never contemplated
would happen to me that come what may I
will trust in the Lord's sovereignty you
know Jenna can I can I keep you around
we've got I've gotta end the show here
for all the unwashed masses in the hoi
polloi we have a member block coming up
I know they're gonna have questions for
you I've got more I've got more
questions before we before we switch
over uh give send go.com support Jenna
that's where you can give to Jenna's
legal defense which I think is a really
great thing to do boy what a great clip
that was huh I really liked it you liked
it too well if you did subscribe ring
the bell to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel we'll see you next time